tell me a little bit about yourself
Sebastian okay I'm an artist a painter
illustrator and uh
California but my parents and all my
families from Argentina so I I came back
to to Argentina when I saw when I was a
little boy so now I live in Argentina
I'm an Argentinian oh wow okay and you
said you're a painter are those your
paintings behind you
oh my God
you're okay thanks thanks he also did
one of someone else we know here I'll
just put this up to the camera oh my God
look at that did you did you do that
Sebastian
well yes uh I was starting some Irish
history and it came along that that
character I oh my God you I have to say
um you've got the proportions right
you've got the long legs
and uh you were thank you you were a
little generous with the with the Torso
with the chest
and everything looks uh pretty much spot
on he has dress shoes on yeah
that's how I that's how my clan always
dressed back in Ireland hundreds of
years ago um Sebastian you're very
talented
okay thank you thank you have you have
you done artwork uh that's you know been
used internationally yeah yeah
20 years I I work with so many Medias
and uh I do paintings for
famous celebrities and uh rock stars can
you tell us can you can you tell us
which rock stars you've done paintings
for well I'm done
[Music]
I'm done for the black Crowd Oh my God I
love I love all those groups I really
love the black crows I love those guys
yeah they are amazing yeah wow that's
very impressive
um tell me uh Sebastian I'm curious
because you've if I were to ask you to
paint me
uh what what would your approach no I
know no I know you did I know you did
and it's very good but I guess what I'm
asking you is what have you noticed
about me that stands out in a portrait
you know well uh you're here it's it's
it's it's notorious and no it hasn't
committed any crimes Sebastian yeah I
love that my hair is notorious so you
think the hair is the first thing you
have to nail in your artistic approach
yeah
yeah the character you could do the hair
good but the face is not good it's gonna
be like
really really weird yes you have like a
chin like a
like a tomato soup tin you know wait
wait a minute wait wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute with hellofresh you
get farm fresh pre-proportioned
ingredients I like things
pre-proportioned and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store and count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable that's why it's America's
number one meal kit that's cool have you
used hello fresh before I have used
hello fresh what I like about them is
they they do really give you just what
you need for the recipe yes it's it's
kind of hard to screw up and I'm not
insulting you but that would be
important wow it does sound like you're
insulting me but what I also mean is
even Sona can do it okay you know what
that I don't don't know that's a
compliment but I don't like that there's
stuff left over that's rotting in the
fridge if I'm not using exactly what you
need it is
pre-proportionate and it's recipes I
never even thought about making before
which I love Yeah it widens your uh
scope as a chef go to hell refresh.com
team coco16 use code team coco16 for 16
free meals plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com team coco16. hello fresh
America's number one meal kit wait a
minute I have a tomato soup can chin you
say that like we should know what you
mean what do you mean I have a tomato
soup can chin and I'm not saying you're
wrong I just go ahead I just want to
know what you mean
the Campbell the Campbell Soup I don't
care what type of soup it is I want to
know why my chin is like a can of tomato
soup you're like I don't know the the
name in English but you you have the
like your face is like very proportional
like like it's done like with with with
metal you know like I look like my face
was hang was bashed out of metal
I look like someone just took a a hubcap
from a car and just bashed it with a
hammer like that yeah there you go
that's that's what I look like like I
was smashed out of metal
are you saying that I have now first of
all my face is very proportionate right
yes yes it is and if you notice that I
have sharp cheekbones
yes
you are very handsome thank you and
Sebastian I thank you for that because
I'm looking at you and I'm thinking you
look like you know uh what is his name
Krista waldow from
Nicholas yeah you look like Nikolai
Costa Waldo from Game of Thrones you
look like do you mean Lannister yeah
yeah but if he were a bottle of candy
guy no no no no no no no the king Slayer
the one that gets his hand chopped off
sorry spoiler alert
um no no I know I know that I know that
I don't cut the the same luck because he
lost the hands yeah no no you I didn't
mean you're so good looking you're gonna
get your hand chopped off I just said
you look like Nikolai kosterwaldau uh
and you should be very happy you're a
very good looking fellow and I'd like to
just repeat that you thought that I'm a
very good looking fellow is that true
you are you you are man yeah let's talk
more about it
go ahead imitate your hair but I cannot
do it it's not forever for any for
everyone for anyone
see you you meant to say my hair is not
for everyone but you said it's not for
anyone
yeah
it's notorious it's a war criminal so um
do you think maybe I should change my
hair now or is it too late no never okay
I'm not going to change my once you
change it to you just like slick it back
I don't know I can do whatever I want
all right I'm sorry I've got hundreds of
dollars
um Sebastian uh this intrigues me
um I'm interested I've never tried
painting but do you think that maybe I
could become a painter yes you can yes
you can you have all the skills how do
you know you you you you you should look
like uh like a German painter you know
something like that from the Renaissance
okay so you're saying that I have all
the skills and then I asked you what do
I have and you say well you sort of look
like a German painter but yeah but you
don't know that I have any painting
skill
no you don't I don't know I don't I
don't the look is 100
uh
Sebastian is this how you pick a surgeon
when you need surgery I want that guy he
just looks like a surgeon yeah
[Music]
you look good man I love that I love I
love your attitude Sebastian
and I'm really sorry that you about your
upcoming heart surgery I don't think
it's going to go well when you're
plumber I
I